first Angie got killed naturally and
then so Tessa was blown up cuz there's
some real bomb Mill bomb this is the
nail bomb making it look like which the
roofers they killed him
it goes back to Angelo Bruno who got
Tony
captain arrow to be his constantly here
mm-hmm and Tony actually didn't like get
along with Ange he wanted to make more
he wanted to be the boss too
so he went to New York to complain about
ang because he was friendly with the
guys in New York and this Frank Thierry
and this fella told him said look dude
do what you got to do when ang strained
it out you know so he took it where the
guy was telling him to kill Angelo Buono
so he set it up where John Stanford
would drop the window where they were
parked out in front of Angelo Bruno's
house and as they were sitting there
talking Stamford lowered anxious window
and Tony hit him with a shotgun behind
his head and killed him and after that
every maybe everything went really crazy
we didn't know who did it and everything
really went bad now I've heard a lot of
different versions of why Angelo got
killed
what what story do you know why he got
killed he wanted to take over he wanted
to be the boss gotta that's that's
pretty much it that's it Wow that and by
being the boss you're gonna have a ton
of money coming in he was shaking down
Long John
as soon as Ainge was killed he grabbed
Long John who was Angelo Bruno's big
earner cause he was the drug dealer and
told them how much he wants and how my
asked him how much you make how much you
got coming in and this is how much I
want this is how much I want you just
got to give me what I what's he making
at the time before he I tell you they
were selling that p2p from what we found
out and he came in 55-gallon drums and
contractors cement contractors would use
it by throwing it in the concrete from
what I understand they would make a half
a million dollars on the 55-gallon drums
they would get the drums for nothing of
course they contractors didn't know what
they were using a four by me p2p with it
and they were making a ton of money
after a million dollars per drum yeah
and how many drums were they moving a
ton of them I don't know I'm a Thomas
you're not talking like a lot of them so
you said when this happened you said
things got very ugly what does that mean
things out there
well we didn't know who killed Ange we
wanted to find out my uncle went to New
York sat down with guys New York was
really upset
like you know loss has killed the
Commission like his saying whoa what's
going on here who could the okay for
this
my uncle finally he's trying to get
everything together find out what was
going on Phil testa didn't go to New
York he was afraid to why's that
he didn't know anybody in New York and
my uncle was the guy he knew everybody
so as he met with the chin Fat Tony and
everybody trying to find out what
happened they called Frank's and own up
there to find out and aunt his cousin
did they ever find out who did it they
found out who did it they finally called
I can't think of his name all these
things that were talking about the first
time I'm thinking about him in a long
time and it's actually a good thing it
means that you've gone back to having a
normal life like these are nice things
that you talk about other places ever
think about him you never think about
him no not at all not at all kappa negro
so there's a meeting the cabin Ygritte
they call it the first time they call
Caponigro
he don't show up so my uncle's there
waiting they finally okay try and get
ahold of Nick tell him to come so they
sent for him again and they said who
gave you the okay to kill Ange and he
told him about Frank here said well I
talked to him he gave me the okay and he
said I didn't give you the okay I just
told you to straighten it out I didn't
tell you to kill him so right there they
killed him they took him and they they
tortured him they stuck $20 bills off
his ass really gave him a tough way to
die now was this was anybody playing
games behind closed doors that somebody
did manipulate him into kicking him out
yeah okay yeah he flayed him to kill
ants because there was a big bookmaking
business up in North Jersey that Thierry
wanted a piece of and with him out of
the way he had no problem taking it over
if it was played and manipulated that he
did it then why take him out is it to
say that it wasn't our call it was
somebody else that decided to do it and
she wasn't popular wasn't popular with
the Commission he'd be close to was here
is your Paul Castellano type of guy
where he was just a money guy war yeah
he was just a money guy Carlo Gambino
was his man when Carlo Gambino died he
lost all his power ang
I mean Castellano didn't like them none
of them guys really so what's coming
everybody know it's kind of coming yeah
so then they handle the killer the way
they do this so I didn't tell you to
kill him I just told you you know do
what you need to do what happens after
that was that a statement to the
marketplace that if you do anything
that's the college I make an example of
them yeah you're gonna kill a boss
you're definitely just what's going to
happen without the okay you want to kill
somebody without get the okay this is
what happens after that they wanted to
make my uncle action to Boston
Philadelphia at that time what he said
no she said Phil test has been done
their boss for a long time he said
Mickey said no yeah my uncle said no
even as a power-hungry guy like him said
no no he figured he was close with Phil
testa okay and he said look he's been
anxious underboss and them a long time
he said well they but he better make you
the underboss then he said yeah I'm sure
he will which he did he didn't know he
mayn't Pete Casella his underboss and
the reason he made pika cell is on the
boss because he's a cijxij Leon he said
gee and he made my uncle to consigliere
it said she is somebody from Sicily yes
okay and and for full disclosure it's
not a curse Ward it's not a bad word
nickname
it's a metaphor folks from Sicily yes
and is there some rivalry where worse
you know some folks from Italy don't
like each other is there well it's a
rivalry where the civilians think
they're the true Italians and they don't
consider anybody else Italian like we
won't be considered Italian to them
really man interesting and that's pretty
obvious everyone it's obvious you okay
and and how what is what matters to them
the most is that money is it right as a
loyalty is low yeah they're their money
people above everything yeah and that's
also known it isn't cut so so then what
happens next
now this P Casella was a real he used to
be a drug dealer years ago when he said
he was out of the business and all this
he didn't have any money he got hooked
up with chicken or doochie who had a lot
of money and chicky Narducci talked him
into killing Phil testa mmm-hmm where
Pete would become the boss and chicky
Narducci would become the underboss and
he laid a lot of money on them what
happens they made this plan where the
casella's were good with bombs
because he had a brother Tony Cassell
also and they had this kid that said a
bomb near Phil testa house right next to
his door actually he had a wall concrete
wall here on his porch so when Phil went
to go open the door the bomb went off in
the blast blew him all the way to the
back door and killed him and Pete
thought he was going to become the boss
once he was killed after that when we
went in and all that he sent for my
uncle
actually it was at Phil testa's funeral
a week
I'm sorry week Chickie's Narducci was
there and he told my uncle he said he
could seller wants to see it at Johnny
Capello's house which is his
brother-in-law so my uncle says could I
bring Chuckie with me and he said I
don't give a [ __ ] who you bring so right
there we knew something was wrong I grab
Johnny Capel I said what's going on
because I heard what chicky said he said
oh you made me your uncle certain you he
shouldn't go over there I said why
what's why why shouldn't he go so I told
my uncle I said now we're going so I
grab Johnny capella I said come on
you're staying with me if something
happens tell my uncle me to kill you
right here
so we had him at the 9n bar my uncle
went thank god they came out alive he
said when they first got there there was
this kid that set the bomb had a radio
listening for police calls in his ear so
they walked in Pete was there his
brother Tony Pete said look we know who
killed Phil testa he's telling my uncle
and my uncle said Yahoo he said it was
the roofers Union we want you to kill
John McCullough because he's the one he
said John McCullough and kill Phil testa
he said I just send Ralph Napoli to the
chin to find out what's going on over
here I'm gonna send a message that
you're telling me McCullough
killed Phil testa and we'll see what
happens Pete's a talk why we want to
cause problems now you know he said no
this is this is what we're going to do
he send ralph napoli over there to find
out what was going on and all so my
Uncle Sam word with Ralph up to the chin
to make an appointment to go see them
mm-hmm to find out what's going on
so he told Pete Pete was really upset
about that cause he figured you know
it's going to it's going to come out
that he was on Bob would kill him Phil
testa so anyway they left their waiter
for Ralph to come back and had the
appointment with the
and they went up he went up the next day
he told him about what Pete said and all
and told him that he was lying about it
so they sent for a pika so they did yeah
and your reasoning for doing this is for
things to not get out of control where
you were you just kind of trying to
protect yourself as well we were trying
yet we were trying to find out who
killed him we know we didn't do it
because if you won't go the wrong route
and you assume that somebody that who
didn't it could turn into mayhem yeah
Oh God we have to find out who really
killed him we knew it wasn't John
McCullough what was in the roofers a
union they put the nails in the and the
bomb to make it look like it was coming
from the roofers Union were they
assuming or were they trying to play a
power game against you guys what were
they trying to kind of a you know
deflect it on somebody was trying to
deflect them but when you know who
killed them yeah okay ain't no so who
killed them it was Pete Casella and
checking our duty and all the kids they
had around them what's the motive for
them doing that Pete one is beautiful us
because he fun figures once he becomes
the boss I'll make chicky North do
cheating on their boss he'll make a ton
of money chicky would lay a lot of money
on them but see chicky didn't you
understand you just can't become the
boss you got to get approved by the
Commission to be the boss at all off um
hmm so they didn't understand that they
thought they could just become the boss
on their own but they got to be approved
and they found out the hard way
so what happens next so what happens
next we wanted to kill Pete and Tony but
they didn't give us the okay the
Commission didn't give us the okay to
kill Pete so they said look you go to
Florida you're retired get out of here
you're done topeka sella his brother
Tony we got the okay to kill him chicky
Narducci the other fellows the kid they
made the bomb everybody involved we got
the okay to kill everybody you got the
green light for everybody everybody
except for Pete
[Music]